I am genuinely excited at last finally a
videogame I've heard about that I really
want to play battlefield one he's out
now I wanted to play with someone who
was fun who might know the game a little
bit and I brought my pal
Terry Crews you know what I will call
myself a gamer gamer only and I built a
PC for my son and because I wanted to
get close to him you built a PC no I've
had you just blew me out of the water to
be a good gamer you have to know how to
play all the games I'm interested in
this one cuz it's about something I know
about history yes I mean I've read a lot
about World War one so I'm gonna be
looking for the smallest mistake these
guys make and I'm sorry see it I never
know me it's gonna be hard because this
thing is so detailed so incredible you
can hear the breath the is the fire to
flame that's got it it's nuts it's
actually the most beautiful thing I've
ever seen the most beautiful thing
you've ever seen absolutely and you said
you have a son this is the fastest I've
gotten into a game in a long time
usually there's 45 minutes of BS yes
that's human traffic on the 405 look at
that giant step link you can shoot that
step one down when I died in slow-mo
that looked me about really look instead
of attention we found fear and in
Wardian equalizes
this is incredibly heavy heavy man this
is what we're gonna look like six months
into a trump presidency
really if this was gonna be an accurate
game and they should be listening if
they're watching right now 80% of the
players should just go from non-stop
dysentery dysentery just took so never
disturb
bTW what if you would have sprayed these
it's a charge full lashes every once in
a while we push hard enough that the
light breaks through the cloud are they
gonna kiss I mean one of the reasons I
wanted you here for this game is that
you are such a relentlessly positive
person we're all gonna dance all this
okay stop it the emotional part of it is
that you see how long they live like
they give you his birthday and his death
day
this was like a pacman where after you
eat the dot they tell you when the dark
before a picture of the dots mother you
know and then they tell you that the the
dot had a little child dot that it'll
never see again with the soundtrack yeah
and then they play that sad music okay
you need to cheer up do we have of
course the game is about to tell us how
many bunnies died the bunnies were used
as bunny grenades
things like naughty boy that's how my
god fell the tree oh that's kind of sad
I know now show laymen that was a tree
tree 16 22 17 boom you've hit him so
many times why would anything happens
he'll I don't have to have got this game
what's this thing made of ridiculous
you know in life when you see a balloon
and you stick it with a pin you don't
have to keep sticking it with a pen for
40 minutes to see it go down right it's
a balloon you gotta go
he's mocking wait he's mocking the guy
just happened before it went down before
it could go down you crash-landed on it
so now you're on the Zeppelin you have
to kill this guy who's got the
anti-aircraft gun to save the rest your
true theory oh that guy's got to die
[Applause]
falls off the bottom I really want that
thing to fall yes just cut that last
wire those guys are going to so exciting
that I need a bathroom break battlefield
one will make you want to urinate it's
so good out now on Xbox one PC you can
go one and ps4 you gotta get this game I
Love You Man
on 90 what were left to
[Applause]
you